Trascrizione: Lucia Cadamuro
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera,
come spoletino di adozione
penso che sia necessario -
non vedo persone molto conosciute,
e vedo molte persone di fuori-
dire che ci troviamo
nel teatro Caio Melisso.
Anticamente  - questo che vedete oggi
è l'adattamento che è stato fatto
alla metà dell'Ottocento
dall'architetto Montiroli.
L'architetto era stato
l'allievo principale di Canina a Roma
e poi era emigrato in Inghilterra
per servire il duca di Northucumberland
per cui fece due straordinarie ville
e poi tante altre architetture.
Ritornato in Italia,
alla metà dell'Ottocento,
ebbe questo incarico
di rinnovare il teatro.
Perché questo è stato, forse,
uno dei più antichi teatri d'Italia:
addirittura, nel Seicento
era già guarnito di tre ordini di palchi,
ed era il cosiddetto teatro dei nobili.
Poi cadde pian piano in disuso
fino a diventare nel '900 -
nel 1950 era il cosiddetto "pidocchietto",
cioè il luogo dove si veniva a vedere
tutti i film di Jim della giungla,
di tutte queste cose qui.
Poi dopo è stato di nuovo
con il festival, a partire dal 1958,
è stato di nuovo rimesso a posto
e ha assunto l'aspetto che ha oggi:
e come tale, come teatro viene utilizzato.
Basta.
Cominciamo questa chiacchierata
che pensavo di fare insieme con voi.
Ecco: io, quando Stefano Andreini,
che avete sentito poco fa,
mi ha coinvolto in questa operazione qui
dicendo "Ma, devi parlare -".
Quando ho capito che si partiva,
come abbiamo sentito poco fa,
da Leonardo da Vinci,
ho detto “Vabbè! Allora parlerò
dei miei incontri con Leonardo da Vinci”.
Perché ho avuto la fortuna
di incontrarlo ben tre volte.
Tre volte in tre occasioni straordinarie.
Ecco, diciamo che come minimo è dal 2000
che mi interesso di allestimenti,
di mostre, di esposizioni;
e per conto una volta
della Casa Buonarroti,
di cui ero l'architetto di riferimento;
poi, ancora - Casa Buonarroti,
ovviamente, di Firenze -
Poi ancora di questa associazione
culturale "Metamorfosi", di Roma,
che allestisce mostre.
E sollecitato da loro,
ho cominciato appunto a provare
ad allestire delle mostre,
e piano piano ho cominciato.
Per fortuna, per mia fortuna,
ho cominciato da quelli più importanti:
Leonardo, Michelangelo,
Canova - e così via, insomma.
E quindi, ogni volta ho cercato
di affinare sempre di più
questa tecnica, in qualche modo.
Perché fare un allestimento
significa, innanzitutto,
confrontarsi con i curatori scientifici.
I curatori scientifici
di solito sono professoroni,
sono direttori di musei
o sono professori dell'università,
eccetera eccetera,
che mettono a punto, in qualche modo,
un'idea, un'esposizione,
un'interpretazione
delle opere di un artista.
E poi, ancora, mettono a punto
un elenco di oggetti
che devono essere messi
in relazione fra di loro;
e devono essere dati in pasto,
diciamo così, ai visitatori.
E allora cosa si fa?
Quello che è un progetto scientifico
deve diventare praticamente
un allestimento scenografico.
Cioè quello che, aridamente,
è solamente un'opera dietro l'altra -
un quadro, o un arazzo,
una statua e così via -
deve diventare invece
un percorso di emozioni,
deve diventare un uno o più percorsi
dove - con l'aiuto delle luci,
con l'aiuto dei supporti,
con l'aiuto delle musiche
quando è necessario,
con l'aiuto soprattutto
delle didascalie e tutto il resto,
e con un percorso appositamente studiato -
si tenta di far capire al visitatore
qual è l'idea di chi ha inventato
il percorso originario,
qual è l'idea che sottende
quello che è la mostra.
Ecco: io ho incontrato
per tre volte Leonardo.
L’ho incontrato nel 2009,
e l'ho incontrato a Roma.
L'ho incontrato poi nel 2019
in due musei diversi,
in due gallerie diverse:
la Galleria Sabauda di Torino
e la Galleria dell'Accademia di Venezia.
L'occasione erano
i 500 anni dalla sua morte.
La prima volta che l'ho incontrato
è stato, invece, ai palazzi capitolini,
cioè ai Musei Capitolini a Roma,
ed è stata la prima volta
che mi sono accostato
a un'opera di Leonardo,
ed è stata un'esperienza
veramente straordinaria.
L’opera da esporre è questa:
un ritratto di musico,
si chiama "Ritratto di musico".
È proprietà della Biblioteca
Ambrosiana di Milano
e non si era mai spostata
da Milano, dalla biblioteca.
Fu prestata, unica opera,
dai Musei Capitolini:
è un'opera molto piccola,
un'opera anche questa misteriosa
come tutte le opere, o quasi, di Leonardo.
È un ritratto, cioè circa 40 centimetri,
45 centimetri per 33, una cosa del genere.
Quindi, immaginate, meno
di un foglio formato A4.
E "Ritratto di Musico" perché?
Perché questo gentiluomo -
è di circa la metà del Cinquecento,
della seconda metà del Cinquecento -
regge con la mano destra una carta,
sulla carta c'è un pentagramma,
cioè cinque righe del pentagramma,
e ci sono delle note:
"Ritratto di musico".
Non sappiamo altro.
Però è un’opera delicatissima,
è un'opera estremamente affascinante,
è un'opera seducente in qualche modo.
Il problema grande che c'è,
quando mi dissero di esporre queste opere,
era costituito dal fatto
che il luogo destinato
a esporre quest'opera -
ripeto, delicatissima -
era il giardino, il "Giardino Romano".
Il "Giardino Romano"
è quella straordinaria vetrata
che copre una gran parte
dei cortili dei palazzi capitolini,
dove viene custodita e conservata
la statua di Marco Aurelio -
quella originale,
perché quella che sta
in piazza è una copia.
E poi, ancora, ci sono
tantissimi altri oggetti
archeologici importanti,
come la mano di Costantino
col dito alzato e così via.
Quindi per impedire: uno,
che la luce rovinasse il dipinto;
e poi, ancora, per impedire
che questo dipinto fosse
in qualche modo soffocato
da tutto quanto quello che stava attorno,
inventai una specie di teca.
Ecco questa è una versione
assonometrica della teca.
L'oggetto era costruito in legno -
ovviamente ignifugato,
e tutto quanto il resto.
Andiamo avanti.
Questo è il modello.
E poi, ancora, c'è una sezione
in cui si capisce qual era stata
la trovata in qualche modo importante:
è questa, cioè l'opera era chiusa
dentro questa specie di tabernacolo,
questa specie di teca.
Era illuminata dall'alto,
e quindi non c'era nessuna ombra
che si proiettava sull'opera stessa.
L'opera era posizionata
alla distanza giusta di visuale,
e all'altezza giusta.
Poi ancora l'opera
non era appesa alla parete,
appoggiata su una parete;
ma era appoggiata su una tavola
che non si vedeva;
dietro la tavola c'era
una piccolissima luce,
per cui quest'opera -
i cui limiti non si vedevano -
galleggiava nel buio assoluto
di questo tabernacolo.
Ecco: questo è l'oggetto,
questo è il giorno dell'inaugurazione
e questo era il rapporto
che si veniva a istituire:
praticamente, il visitatore
che guardava attentamente -
e che era da solo,
al massimo due persone potevano sostare -
entrava direttamente in collegamento
in qualche modo con l'opera stessa,
cioè interrogava l’opera
e otteneva le risposte, in qualche modo:
quindi era un rapporto diretto,
emozionante, veramente seducente.
La seconda volta che, come dicevo prima,
ho incontrato Leonardo -
questa è la pianta
della Galleria Sabauda a Torino.
La Galleria Sabauda, come potete vedere,
ha tantissimi spazi:
però l'opera più importante,
fra tante altre che erano
all'interno della mostra,
come i disegni, chiaramente di Leonardo -
bellissimi, seducenti, straordinari -
ce n’è uno piuttosto bello
di anatomia, questo qui.
Il disegno più importante
era il cosiddetto autoritratto,
quello che viene definito
"l'autoritratto".
Anche in questo caso, mi trovai a fare
una scelta molto forte,
cioè isolai completamente questa
che era l'opera più importante,
erano circa 70 anni
che non veniva aperto il baule
in cui era conservata al buio.
Per cui anche in questo trovai
questa sezione numero quattro,
cioè una stanza praticamente quasi tutta
dedicata completamente a lui e basta.
Che stava in fondo
a questa stanza stretta e lunga,
su un fondo completamente nero
e illuminato al massimo possibile:
il massimo possibile
sono "massimo 50 lux", per capirci.
Non certo quello che abbiamo qui dentro.
Per cui, anche qui in questo caso,
se puoi tornare un attimo indietro
c'era un'immagine che interessava.
Anche in questo caso è tutto buio,
ma nel monitor che ho io
ci sono due persone
presenti contemporaneamente,
che stanno guardando
intensamente quest'opera.
È un'opera anche questa,
è inutile che mi prolunghi sulla qualità
e sull'importanza di quest'opera.
Ecco: invece, molto più complessa
anche quella all'Accademia di Venezia,
quando mi trovai in questa ex chiesa
che stava al secondo piano dell'Accademia;
e soprattutto, mi trovai -
cioè, quella di Torino era intitolata
"Leonardo da Vinci - Disegnare il futuro".
Questa era invece intitolata
"Leonardo da Vinci,
l'uomo è misura del mondo".
L'uomo è misura del mondo.
Qual’era l'opera più importante
di tutta quanta l'esposizione?
Era l'"Uomo Vitruviano",
cioè l'uomo con le braccia alzate
e le braccia dritte,
che non è solo il modello,
diciamo, umano per eccellenza,
ma è proprio come una misura,
la misura dell'universo in qualche modo.
Mi trovai, appunto, con opere che erano
estremamente diverse, insomma:
dipinti, statue, sculture,
libri e così via,
per cui fui "costretto" -
la mia scelta fu quella
di, anche qui, inventare una teca,
un luogo completamente chiuso
dove il disegno che ha
un formato, questo sì, tipo A4
era illuminata al massimo
50 Lux, non di più.
Mentre tutto il resto
doveva essere fortemente illuminato,
per cui ho dovuto
richiuderlo un'altra volta,
un po’ come la prima soluzione.
Giù in fondo nell'abside,
della sezione su in alto,
c'era questa teca.
Vediamo le fotografie.
Ecco: questo è durante l'allestimento.
Questo è l'ambiente,
ci stanno ancora tutte le opere
messe alle pareti, ma coperte ancora;
e giù in fondo vedete la teca
in colore argento, in argento proprio,
a cui si accedeva con una lunga passerella
perché ci sono tre gradini,
e quindi dovevo superare
questo ostacolo in qualche modo.
Però, allo stesso tempo
era bello vedere gente incolonnata
che piano piano saliva, arrivava, leggeva,
interrogava il quadro, in qualche modo,
e riceveva le sue risposte.
E poi ancora si allontanava.
Ecco: questa è stata -
andiamo avanti, c'è ancora un'immagine
in cui si vede già l'opera
montata all'interno,
e poi ancora ce ne dovrebbe essere una
in cui si vedono due persone.
Questi stanno montando ancora l'opera.
Quindi, di fronte a questa
apertura verticale
si sostava, si interrogava
l'opera, in qualche modo,
si otteneva le risposte
che si volevano ottenere,
e poi ci si allontanava.
Cioè, tutte e tre le volte
praticamente che cosa ho fatto?
Ho fatto in modo
che la lettura dell'opera,
la visione dell'opera
non fosse disturbata
assolutamente da niente.
Ho fatto in modo che si entrasse
direttamente in colloquio con l'opera.
E ci si potesse fondere con quella,
cioè sentirne le vibrazioni,
sentirne la forza e tutto quanto il resto.
Quindi - una cosa importante.
Non ho mai partecipato -
avrò allestito 50, 60 mostre -
non ho mai partecipato
a nessuna inaugurazione.
Ma sono tornato più volte,
in incognito, a vedere le reazioni:
a vedere non le opere,
che tanto le conoscevo.
Anzi, le ho dovute studiare:
le avevo misurate, avevo stabilito
dove metterle, come metterle eccetera.
Sono andato, sempre,
con la curiosità di vedere
qual era la reazione delle persone,
come le persone reagivano,
come le persone si relazionavano
con quell'opera.
In che modo la incontravano,
in che modo la lasciavano.
E qui è avvenuta veramente
questa rivelazione molto importante,
che adesso vi farò, ma è
supportata da fatti scientifici;
l'opera d'arte,
la fruizione dell'opera d'arte
fa bene non solo allo spirito,
ma fa bene anche al corpo.
Ti mette in pace non solo con te stesso,
ma con tutti quanti gli altri.
Ci sono dei bellissimi studi,
fatti dalla University College of London,
che - sono circa tremila studi
che sono stati fatti -
che ti dimostrano come la frequentazione
di un'opera d'arte -
e con opera d'arte intendo
qualunque opera d'arte:
può essere un bel libro,
può essere un bel film,
può essere un bello spettacolo teatrale,
può essere una musica,
può essere un quadro,
può essere un concerto e così via,
ti rilassa, ti mette
in pace con te stesso,
cioè è in grado di guarirti
le ferite dello spirito, sicuramente;
di farti stare meglio in qualche modo.
C'è questo Zeki,
della University College di Londra,
che ha messo a punto la "neuro-estetica",
una branca diciamo:
la neuro estetica è lo studio
di come reagisce una persona
in un colloquio con un'opera d'arte,
in rapporto con un'opera d'arte.
Ha individuato una parte del cervello,
nella parte centrale,
che viene stimolata fortemente;
e più fortemente viene stimolata,
maggiore il benessere che uno ne ricava.
Ecco, e questo è importante:
cioè significa che la bellezza,
significa che la mostra,
che è il mio mestiere,
non è solamente un fatto estetico,
è un fatto emozionale.
Che la bellezza, che l'arte
è una sorta di medicina del nostro essere,
del nostro modo di relazionarci
con il mondo che abbiamo attorno.
Ecco, questa è una grande scoperta;
e quando, curando un allestimento,
tu, adoperando tutti i mezzi
possibili e immaginabili,
cioè quelli normali che sono le luci,
che sono le didascalie,
che sono la posizione
dove metti questo oggetto,
l'altezza,  la posizione,
le luci che gli dai e così via,
in che modo lo incontra il visitatore?
Magari all'improvviso,
magari al centro di una stanza,
oppure dietro un angolo.
Ecco che quindi comportano diciamo,
la scoperta, la meraviglia ecc.
Ecco: quando riesci a raggiungere questo,
significa che il tuo mestiere
l’hai fatto, e l’hai fatto bene.
Grazie.